It took Grant a while to process the
orders that he had gotten from the school,
and from Mr. Belvedere, but in the end, he
finally had a moment to relax. He had
visions of little children running around
with glasses, wipers, and nozzles, and of
course, of his new friend. What a nice old
man. He felt so excited and so satisfied
that, pretty soon, his products would be
keeping the glasses of people all over the
world nice and clean, but he realized he'd
left out one major detail. He hadn't yet
set the price for his wipers or for his
nozzles. In terms of the equation that we
came up with for his total future
earnings, he hadn't picked a value for w
yet, or one for n. Remember that w is equal
the price per wiper blade set and n is
just equal to the price per nozzle. Grant
thought long and hard about how much he
wanted to charge for each wiper blade set
and for each nozzle. But finally, he came
to a decision, he set the price per wiper
blade set at $30 and he set the price per
nozzle at $12. Now, these might look like
kind of steep prices, but, hey, Grant had
worked really hard on both of his products
and they're actually pretty intricate
designs. Takes a lot of work to make
nozzles and wipers this small that aren't
just going to break their first use.